lo que está en juego es muy grande más
grande que en cualquier momento de la
historia moderna muchos hemos estado
preocupados por el camino que hemos
estado siguiendo en los últimos cuatro
años es un camino que nos ha llevado a
la división a la disfunción a la
irresponsabilidad y a generar conflictos
entre nuestros ciudadanos con seguir por
ese camino va a tener consecuencias
terribles para el alma estadounidense
porque nos están llevando por la ruta
equivocada por un presidente que nos ha
puesto unos contra otros es el va en
contra de los otros líderes que hemos
tenido que han tratado de acabar con
nuestras diferencias en llevarnos hacia
un estados unidos unidos yo soy un
republicano de larga data pero eso queda
en segundo lugar con respecto a mi
responsabilidad con este país es por eso
que he decidido aparecer en esta
convención en tiempos normales esto
probablemente nunca ocurriría pero estos
no son tiempos normales me siento
orgulloso de la herencia republicana es
el partido de lincoln que él fundó sobre
un gran propósito
lo que he sido testigo en los últimos
años va en contra de sus principios
muchos de nosotros no podemos imaginar
otros cuatro años por este mismo camino
y es por eso que les estoy pidiendo que
se unan a mí en elegir una mejor manera
una mejor vida creo que lo mejor de eeuu
está por venir pero solo cuando volvamos
a descubrir nuestra creencia en un
estados unidos de américa por el futuro
de nuestros hijos que puede ser
brillante el lleno de esperanza
inspirado
si elegimos que sea de esa manera he
conocido el ior vaivén por 30 años
conozco su historia de dolor que ha
afectado su carácter de manera profunda
sé que él es un buen hombre un hombre de
fe un unificador una persona que
comprende las esperanzas los sueños del
hombre común y de la mujer común es un
hombre que puede ayudarnos a ver la
humanidad en cada uno de nosotros él
sabe que el pasado el para el camino
para restaurar esto viene de la unidad y
del propósito común para todos sí
en áreas donde él y yo estamos
absolutamente en desacuerdo pero eso
está bien porque de eso se trata este
país porque a pesar de las diferencias
nos respetamos como seres humanos cada
uno de nosotros buscando justicia y
buscando propósito
todos podemos ver lo que está ocurriendo
en nuestro país el día de hoy y todas
las preguntas
que enfrentamos en un buena persona o
partido tiene las respuestas pero lo que
sí sabemos es que podemos hacer algo
mejor de lo que hemos estado viendo hoy
y sé que yo bailén con su experiencia y
su sabiduría y su decencia pueden
unirnos para ayudarnos a encontrar esa
mejor manera estoy seguro de que hay
republicanos e independientes que no
podían imaginar
apoyaron demócratas creen que
job aiden se vaya demasiado la izquierda
pero yo no creo que sea así porque
conozco la mesura de este hombre sé que
es razonable respetuoso lleno de fe y
nadie se mete con él eres una persona
para nuestros tiempos tiempos que hacen
un llamado para que todos nosotros nos
quitemos el gorro partidistas y pensemos
en nosotros y por supuesto pensemos en
nuestros hijos cuando eeuu escoge el
camino correcto
y se une como lo hemos hecho tantas
veces en el pasado podemos soñar en
grande y podemos ver el final de la
montaña como un eeuu unidos con una alma
que sea
la esperanza del mundo